Bonjour à toutes et à tous,
Et bienvenue dans le premier épisode de "Un Zeste pour la planète".
Aujourd'hui, on va commencer par vous parler de vous.
- Moi ?
- Non de moi.
- Ben non de moi
Non non non non ! De vous.
Et plus précisément de ce qu'ily a à l'intérieur de vous,
et qui ressort de temps en temps.
De ce que vous produisez,en somme.
Oui oui ... On va parler pipi caca.
Saviez-vous que votre urine, qu'il ne vous
viendrait probablement pas à l'idée de boire,
contient pourtant de précieux nutriments ?
Du phosphore, de l'azote, du potassium,
mais aujourd'hui ce que nos toilettes chassent à grands
renforts d'eau potable
n'atterrit plus que dans les égouts et les stations d'épuration,
où ilfaut ensuite tout traiter.
En plus ces stations d'épuration émettent des tonnes de gaz à effet deserre,
autant que le trafic aérien à l'échelle mondiale.
Et ces stations sont parfois surchargées.
Elles ont bien du mal à faire face à nos besoins...
sans mauvais jeu de mots.
Et lorsqu'elles sontsurchargées, elles déversent donc des eaux encore
trop riches, en phosphate et en azote, dans lesrivières.
Le problème c'est qu'ils produisent des algues indésirables qui menacent labiodiversité animale et végétale dans nos cours d'eau.
Alors comment soulager les stationsd'épuration et réorienter le potentiel fertilisateur de l'urine là où on en a vraimentbesoin ?
On en revient donc à nos toilettes.
Pour faciliter le recyclage de ces nutriments,
le plus simple serait de commencer par séparer les déchets, dès la cuvette.
Alors comment?
Ouh ouh ouh
En arrêtant de faire pipi debouuuut
Ouh ouuuuuuh
Tu recycles tout, ouh
Pour le savoir, directionToulouse.
Ici des scientifiques ont un projet pour le moins ambitieux :
développer les toilettes dufutur.
Les chercheurs ont eu une idée toute simple,
mais ingénieuse.
Traiter les déchets produits parnotre corps, comme tous les autres déchets,
en les séparant à la source.
Sur ce prototype de toilette,conçu par les scientifiques toulousains,
une grille de séparation permet d'évacuer directement l'urine
par un canal différent de celui suivi par les excréments.
Un peu comme on le fait chez vous,quoi !
Le plastique, c'est là.
Le carton, c'est là.
Le caca, c'est là.
Non !
Oui, enfin pour que ça marche,il y a quand même une contrainte.
Il faudrait que ces messieurs acceptent enfin de faire pipi assis.
Si c'est pastrop demander.
Et l'autre truc ingénieux, dans le système conçu par nos ingénieurs toulousains,
c'est qu'on arrête de gaspiller l'eau potable.
Au lieu d'être emporté par une chasse d'eau,
quiutilise entre 3 et 9 litres d'eau potable,
les déchets sont évacués sous vide,
c'est-à-dire parde l'air et un tout petit peu d'eau,
comme dans les avions ou dans les trains,
des endroits oùl'on manque d'eau,
comme sur Terre, quoi...
Hein ?
Bref !
Grâce à ces toilettes intelligentes, on peut
récupérer l'urine pure, propre,
comme on les aime.
Il ne reste plus ensuite qu'à en extrairela substantifique moelle.
Autrement dit, les fameux nutriments.
Ah ouais, mais du coup çase mange ?
[ - Non Jen', c'est juste pour les plantes, là]
Ah !
OK
Et là encore les chercheurs ontdéveloppé une méthode innovante et efficace
pour produire de l'engrais directementà partir d'une urine récupérée lors d'événements à forte concentrationhumaine et urinaire,...
les festivals.
Hein quoi ?
Alors comment on fait ?
On verse l'urine dans unecentrifugeuse.
On y ajoute du magnésium.
Et hop !
On lance la machine.
On obtient de la struvite.
Celapermet de créer un produit phosphoré en grains qui ressemble beaucoup aux engrais classiqueset qui peut d'ores et déjà être utilisé comme fertilisant.
Mais si vous avez à peu près suivijusqu'ici, vous allez me demander :
Oui, mais l'azote ?
Il est où l'azote ?
Je sais bien, on pose cettequestion dix fois par jour.
Pour récupérer l'azote, on a recours à une technique particulièrementnovatrice :
la chimio-sorption transmembranaire ou TMCS.
Voilà ! A bientôt !
Abonnez-vous !
Bon ! D'accord, je vais essayer de vous l'expliquer.
L'azote de l'urine s'est naturellement transformé enammoniac.
Avec cette technique, on fait passer cet ammoniac
sous forme de gaz à travers unemembrane
pour pouvoir récupérer l'azote.
Il est ensuite capté à l'aide d'une solution d'acide
sulfurique produisant ainsi une solution de sulfate d'ammonium.
Et ça ça ne vous dit peut-êtrerien, mais c'est un fertilisant,
comme ceux qu'on peut trouver dans le commerce,
mais en propre.
D'autantplus que les engrais chimiques, que nous utilisons actuellement
dans l'agriculture intensive, sonttrès énergivores,
et surtout issus de ressources fossiles.
Autrement dit pas super top pour laplanète.
Et nous, la planète, on y tient un peu.
Mais soyons encore plus concret.
Ce n'est peut-êtrepas pour tout de suite,
mais dans quelques années,
on pourra peut-être fournir Paris en pain,
grâceà du blé fertilisé par nos toilettes,
ou encore alimenter un festival en bière,
avec l'urine del'édition précédente.
- Une nouvelle bière
- Merci
- C'est pas de la bière ça !